[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى هذه الساعه من العربيه
نواصل فيها تغطيتنا لتداعيات زلزال تركيا
وسوريا ونبدا بالعناوين
تابعوا ايام الزلزال اكثر من 30 الف ضحيه
في تركيا وسوريا وامال النجاه تتلاشى
الامم المتحده تقر بفشلها في ايصال
المساعدات للسوريين وتتهم هيئه تحرير
الشام بعرقلته
المعجزات تحدث نجاه اشخاص في مدن تركيا
بعد 150 ساعه قضوها تحت انقاذ الزلزال
[موسيقى]
تابعوا ايام الكارثه بعد زلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا الاثنين الماضي
اكثر من 30 الف قتيل حصيله الزلزال في
البلدين دمار هائل ايضا طار العديد من
المدن
فرق البحث والانقاذ بالامل الاخير
وبمعجزات في العثور على احياء تحت ركامي
انقاذ الزلزال الذي ضرب 10 ولايات تركيه
بعد مضي سبعه ايام عليه وذكر مراسل
العربيه ان فرق البحث والانقاذ تواصل
محاولاتها ضد عقارب الساعه مع استمرار
عمليات ازاله انقاض المباني التي اكتملت
اعمال البحث والانقاذ فيها بعد انقطاع
الامل في العثور على احيانا ونجحت فرق
لانقاذ في اخراج خمسه افراد من عائله
واحده من تحت انقاض منزرهم في بلده نورداغ
في ولايه غازي عنتاب رضيعه تبلغ من العمر
سته اشهر ووالدتها من تحت الانقاض في
وزير زراعه التركيه وحيد كيريشتي اكد بان
جميع سدود ومحطات الطاقه في البلاد بحاله
جيده وان الفرق المتخصصه بالتدقيق تقوم
بالفحص اليومي لها بعد الهزات الارضيه
التي ضربت البلاد على مدى الايام الماضيه
كريشتي اكد ان جميع محطات الطاقه بحاله
جيده ولا توجد اي تسريبات سواء في السدود
او في المحطات الهيدروليكيه وان السلطات
التركيه اتخذت جميع التدابير والاحتياطات
اللازمه بشان جميع السدود مشيرا الى ان
هناك بعض التشققات لكنها ليست بسبب
الزلزال
ينضم الينا مفرد العربيه عمار الهنديه
عمار مرحبا بك ماذا عن جديد جهود الانقاذ
في هاتين
خالد لعل الصوره يعني توصل المشهد اكثر من
كلماتي وما استطيع ان اوصل انا من خلال
العبارات الناس لا تزال تنتظر نحن في وسط
طبعا حي منكوب بالكامل عمال الانقاذ وفرق
الانقاذ لا تزال تعمل والناس في المقابل
لا تزال تنتظر العائلات لا تزال تنتظر
العثور على اشخاص تحت الانقاض هذه على
يساري عائلات تجلس هنا تنتظر
ان يتم العثور على المفقودين تحت الالقاب
ومعرفه مصيرهم سواء يعني هل وجد احياء
منهم او حتى اموات لان الجميع هنا يطالب
ويطلب خالد بدفن من لديه تحت الانقاض
والعثور عليه ومعرفه مصيره طبعا المشهد
يعني مرعب جدا اينما نظرت هنالك دمار
وهنالك اعمال طبعا تجري يعني بتسابق الزمن
ولكن رغم ذلك كان اليوم هنالك طبعا في هذا
الحي الذي اقف فيه كان هنالك بصيص امل
جديد حيث تم اخراج شاب اسمه عبد الله من
تحت الانقاض بعد 151 ساعه قضاها ونحن يعني
شاهدناه وكان مستيقظ ومدرك تماما لما يحدث
ولكن الدمار هائل اعداد كثيره من الناس
بحسب ما سمعت من شهادات لا تزال تحت
الانقاض اسر كثيره لا يعني تنتظر هنالك
نتحدث عن اربع اشخاص لديه لا زالوا تحت
الانقاض واخر يتحدث عن عشره واخر يتحدث عن
شخص هنالك اعداد كبيره على ما يبدو لا
تزال تحت الانقاذ هذه الاعمال التي تجري
خالد وتشاهدها على الهواء تنتشر في كل
احياء انطاكيا في كل احياء هاتاي المدمره
وعموم تركيا طبعا هي تعطي نموذجا لما يحدث
في تركيا عموما
طبعا كمان كنا رصدنا قبل قليل خالد
ولا اعلم ان كنت شاهدته فيديو من المقبره
من مقبره هاتاي التي يدفت فيها ضحايا هذا
الزلزال لانني في الواقع كنت وقفت هنا على
مسافه تقريبا 100 متر من حيث اقف على جثه
موضوعه في الطريق الى جانب مبنى استخرجت
من جانب المبنى وهذه الجثه تنتظر 24 ساعه
لحين ان ياتي شخص يتعرف عليها من اقاربها
وان لم يحدث ذلك يسار يسار الى نقلها الى
المقبره الجديده في هاتاي وهناك خالد هذه
الاليه ساشرحها لك كيف تحدث هنالك تاتي
الجثه يستقبلها مركز من المسعفين يقوم
بتصوير
الجثه واعطائها رقم وبعد ذلك تدفن
وتخزن لديهم في البيانات في حال جاء شخص
يبحث عن مصير هذه الجثه او هذا هذا
المفقود يستطيع ان يعرف حينها اين وجد اين
اين وجد واين دفن وبالتالي هذه الحاله
التي يعني تحدث الان تحدث بكثره لانه كل
الجثانين التي تخرج الان في اليوم السابع
من هذا الزلزال خالد يعني كما تعلم للاسف
الشديد حالات الانقاذ اليوم يعني خفيفه
وقليله وليست كسابق الايام وبالتالي في
المقابل هنالك يعني اعداد كبيره من
الجثانيين التي يتم اخراجها طبعا حينما
تخرج جثه يكون هنالك اقارب لهذا الشخص
ياتون فورا يستدعيهم الرجل الجيش رجال
الجيش طبعا ينتشرون الان وهذا ما تغير عن
الايام الماضيه رجال الجيش ينتشرون في كل
المباني كل مبنى مدمر تجد فيه عنصر من
قوات الجيش يقف على العمل وعلى فرق
الانقاذ كيف تعمل وعلى الجثامين حينما
تخرج وبمجرد ان يخرج جثمان يستدعي احد من
الاهالي والاسر المتواجده ويطلب منه ان
يتعرف على هذه الجثه اذا ما كانت الجثه
التي تخصه او لا واذا تعرف عليها طبعا
يستطيع ان يدفنها بمعرفته وكما يريد وان
لم يستطع كما قلت له
في هذا المكان في هذه المنطقه عن مر الصوت
لا يصلنا بشكل جيد عموما تشكرك على
متابعتك ورصدك لهذه الصور التي كان ايضا
قد اشار اليها عمار الهندي في متابعه
سابقه هذه مقابر جماعيه
لضحايا الزلزال فيها تايهه تاي تعتبر من
اكثر المدن التي طالها دمار هذا الزلزال
الذي ضرب جزاء من الجنوب التركي والشمال
في سوريا ونتابع معكم ايضا حجم الدمار في
هذه المنطقه في
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
مرحبا بك تتابع يعني منذ ساعات كذلك
عمليات الانقاذ التي تتم في غازيها عنتاب
لاحد المباني المدمره هل من تطورات
عبد المحسن
ايضا ربما ما زالت المشكله كذلك
من غازي عنتاب عموما سنبقى في غازي عنتاب
ونتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
الان نتابع معكم احد هذه المباني المدمره
فرق الانقاذ التي تواصل سعيها الجنوب
بامال ربما تخبو وتتقلص شيئا فشيئا مع
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا ووصول
يعني الوصول اليوم الى اليوم السابع
بالاضافه الى ربما الهزات الارتداديه التي
تزيد من حجم هذه الماسي التي تمر بها هذه
المناطق المنكوبه في الجنوب التركي
والشمال السوري عبد المحسن الحربي الان
ينضم الينا مره اخرى من غازي عنتاب عبد
المحسن المتطورات جديده في عمليات الانقاذ
في غازي عنتاب ايضا
نعم خالد بالفعل خلال ساعات الاولى كانت
الاعمال متلاشيه بايجاد اي شخص حي ويتم
انقاذه في هذا الموقع الا انه قبل قليل
فرق الانقاذ السعوديه استمعت الى صوت تم
تحديد بشكل مبدئي بانه طفل فبالتالي
بدات فرق الانقاذ بالعمل بشكل سريع جدا
على ايجاد خطط معينه للوصول الى هذا الطفل
بداوا من الجهه اليمنى من ثم انتقلوا الى
الجهه اليسرى حين وجدوا موقف للسيارات او
كراج او مدخل ليستطيعوا منه الدخول الى
الجهه الاخرى التي خرج منها صوت هذا الطفل
او المؤشرات الاوليه التي قالت بانه هنالك
صوت لطفل موجود بالاضافه الى المستشعرات
والاجهزه الحديثه التي جربتها فرق البحث
والانقاذ السعودي
رصدت ولو بنسبه ضئيله جدا ولكن تواجد شخص
بالداخل فيتم التعامل معه يعني بعض
الاشخاص المتواجدين هناك من ف انقاذ قال
بانه استمع الى صوت طفل فبالتالي يتم
التعامل مع هذه الحاله ووضع الخطط اللازمه
تغيرت الخطط بعض الشيء بدات من اليمين في
انتقلت الى اليسار والان عمليات ايضا
عمليه صعبه ومعقده سيقوم فيها فريق
الانقاذ من خلال ربما خلال لحظات القليله
القادمه سيدخل احد الافراد الى هذا المدخل
الذي تم اكتشافه بشكل شخصي ليستطلع الطرق
المؤديه الى مكان الطفل في هذا الموقع قبل
قليل ايضا قبل اقل من ساعه تم طلب وضع
لحظه الصمت
لمده عشرين دقيقه وايضا خلال ربما النصف
ساعه الماضيه شاهدت عدد من فرق الانقاذ
تطلب الماء للدخول الى هناك ربما
الاستعداد ايضا فرق
تركيا سياره الاسعاف تواجدت في الطرف
الاخر بعد لحظه الصمت وجود امال
بعمليه انقاذ لشخص متواجد في الداخل تم
تحديده بشكل مبدئي بانه طفل في غضون ذلك
قبل قليل تم استخراج جثه من الجهه اليسرى
وتم حملها مباشره
وايضا كان هنالك المسؤولون الاتراك في هذه
في اللحظات الماضيه كانوا قد جمعوا
الاهالي المتواجدين في الجهه الاخرى خالد
وتحدثوا معهم قليلا ربما عن هذه الجثه
التي تم استخراجها من هذا المبنى ليتم
التعرف عليها في هذا الموقع وان لم يتم
التعرف عليها يتم وضع وضعها في اماكن قبل
الذهاب بها الى المقابر الجماعيه وقبلها
ايضا وضعها بوضع هذه الجثه ومعلوماتها لكي
تتوفر وترقيمها لكي يحصل اهل اهالي هذه
الجثه على معلومات حياله مصير اهاليهم في
الحقيقه اوضاع ماساويه خالد كما تشاهد
العشرات من الاسر متواجد من الاشخاص يعني
بحاله ماساويه يعيشونها في لحظات ترقب
وتامل لعمل فريق الانقاذ السعودي في الجهه
المقابله بعد خصوصا الامال لديهم ارتفعت
اليوم صباحا عندما نتواجدنا في هذا الموقع
كان الكل يشعر بياس كبير جدا نظرا لمرور
اليوم هو اليوم السابع لحدوث هذه الكارثه
وسقوط هذا المنزل وانهياره فبالتالي تلاشت
الاعمال بوجود اشخاص على قيد الحياه وما
ان دقت لحظه الصمت
واعلنت الصافات وصمت الجميع في صمت مهيب
حتى تلاشى عاده الاعمال من جديد ولو بنسبه
جدا ليتم العمل مباشره من قبل الفرق
الانقاذ على خطط كثيره
ومتعدده ومتنوعه وايضا المحاوله عن كشف
بعض الثغرات التي يمكن من خلالها الوصول
الى هذا الصوت وهذا المؤشر الذي يدل على
وجود شخص حي تم تحديده بشكل مبدئي بانه
الطفل في هذه الساعات الحاسمه خلال ربما
الفريق ولا من خلال الاجهزه ربما اجهزه
الاستشعار بعد التحليله
هنالك جزء من فريق من فرق الانقاذ استمع
الى صوت والجزء الاخر تم
وضع نتائجها او تم استنتاج نتائجهم من
اجهزه الاستشعار التي استشعرت هذا الصوت
بنسبه ضئيله كما تحدث المنقذون نسبه ضئيله
استشعارتها هذه الاجهزه بالاضافه الى
الكلاب البوليسيه المدربه على
شم رائحه
الاشخاص الحيين استطاعت الدخول او ادخلت
الى ذلك المكان لكي يتم التاكد ما اذا كان
موقعه في الجهه اليمنى او اليسرى او تحديد
موقعه بشكل مباشر
ليتم البناء كما تشاهد لو نعمل الكلوز
الان خالد لو نقرب الصوره مع زميل المصور
نشاهد فريق الانقاذ السعودي
يعمل على
الحفر في حفره صغيره يتم فتحها الان في
الاعلى
يعني في لحظات
يتم استخدام اجهزه وادوات حديديه في
محاوله العثور على بعض
المداخل
للدخول وايضا بعض الادله او التاكيدات على
وجود بعض الاشخاص في هذا الموقع تحديدا
يتم استخدام الاجهزه اشاهد في هذه اللحظه
تجمع ما يقارب سبعه من فريق الانقاذ
السعودي ثمانيه ايضا في هذه الزاويه
تحديدا ربما هم وجدوا شيئا في هذه اللحظه
اما دليل على وجود شخص او محاوله لايجاد
ايه ثغره للدخول هذه هذا هو الوضع خالد
تتغير الخطط كل لحظه
لمحاوله الاسراع بشكل كبير جدا للوصول هذا
الصوت وتم طلب لحظه صمت تبقى معك هذه
الصوره ايضا نتابع تجريع عمليه البحث الان
بشكل دقيق بعد ما ذكره الزميل عبد المحسن
الذي يقفل امام هذا المبنى في متابعه هذه
الجهود لفريق الانقاذ السعودي وبعد عن رصد
او رصد صوت لطفل ربما تحت الانقاذ في غازي
عنتاب احد المباني التي دمرت تستخدم الان
الاليات الثقيله
لمحاوله فتح او ازاله بعض الكتل الخرسانيه
من مصدر الصوت ربما هذه العمليات التجري
بشكل دقيق جدا
لتفادي حدوث اي انهيارات
ربما وتداعيات لهذه الكتل الخرسانيه ثم
يتم بعد ذلك من خلال اليات خفيفه وادوات
خفيفه من هذا الفريق الذي نراه امامكم
ربما الحاله التي تجد دائما
لكل فرق الانقاذ تستخدم بعد ذلك ادوات
خفيفه
لمحاوله فتح او الكشف عن ثغرات او فجوات
قريبه من مصدر الصوت في محاوله لادخال او
الدخول من خلال هذا الفريق ومن الكلاب
لربما الوصول الى منطقه هذا سنقف على هذه
الصوره ونذهب الى عمار كالهندي مره اخرى
نعود الى اتاي
عمار من جنوب تركيا الان ينضم الينا مره
اخرى سيتابع عمار الان للوقوف ايضا على
اثر هذا الزلزال
من المدن التركيه في الجنوب التي يعني
نالها اوطالها دمار كبير
عما ارت تفضل
في الحقيقه نحن ايضا هنا في لحظات صمت طلب
للتو منا ان نصمت ونسكت لانهم على ما يبدو
توصلوا الى شخص ناجا تحت الانقاض وبالتالي
سنضطر للصمت
لحين ان ياذنوا لنا بالحديث طيب ولكن
ساترك الكاميرا
يعني تحاول الدخول
وساتحدث بصوت منخفض جدا
خشيه ان نعيق اعمالهم هم يعني
ساتابع معك انا من خلال هذه الصور عمار
يعني
كمان نرى الان هذه مجموعه من المباني
المدمره في الجنوب التركي
الرصد فيها حتى الان ربما يعني عدد كبير
من الوفيات ومقابر ايضا جماعيه دفن في
ودفنت فيها الاشجار والجثث لكل من استطاعت
هذه الفرق
من انتشالها خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
ما زالت المحاولات ايضا دؤوبك كما نرى
وكما شاهدنا على الايام الماضيه من قبل
فرق الانقاذ الموجوده في المناطق المنكوبه
باليهاتهم الثقيله
وبربما طريقه التقليديه التي يستخدمونها
في الكشف عن الاصوات ربما والطلب من
الحاضرين بالصمت ريثما يتم سماع اي صوت او
اي مؤشر ربما يدلهم على وجود اي
من تحت هذه الانقاض لهذه المباني المدمره
اليوم هو السابع
والاعمال تخبو وتتقلص ربما بالعثور على
ناجين بعد مرور سبعه ايام على هذه الفاجعه
وكنا قد اشرنا هذه الصوره الان من غازي
عنتاب غازي عنتاب نعود الى الصوره في غازي
عنتاب هذا هو الفريق السعودي الذي يستمر
كذلك في جهود الانقاذ في رفع
الانقاض من احد هذه المباني المدمره التي
استلمهم الفريق السعودي بشكل كامل لديه
ربما من الامكانيات والمعدات التي تؤهله
لك في الاستمرار في عمليه البحث بشكل جيد
تفضل عبد المحسن
نعم خالد ربما تم وضع فتح او الوصول الى
اقل من سنتيمترات شاهدت بعض المعدات التي
تم استخراجها او الادوات المنزليه التي تم
استخراجها من هذا
تعود الصوره مره اخرى الى صور
او من غازي عنتاب من موقع اخر ربما لاحد
المباني
المدمره
غازي عنتاب مثلها ايضا مثل المناطق اخرى
ابطالها دمار لكنه اقل ربما من مناطق
اخرى ايضا في الجنوب التركي
كرمان مره الى هاتاي وغيرها من المناطق
والولايات التركيه
التي كانت دمار فيها كبيرا حسب ما نشاهد
وطال مئات المباني في هذه المناطق
نذهب الى سوريا مع دخول اليوم السابع من
الزلزال الذي ضرب ايضا مناطق في الجنوب
التركي والشمال الغربي من سوريا قاره
الامم المتحده بفشلها في مساعده المنكوبين
ودعا وكيل امين عام الامم المتحده الى
تصحيح الاخفاقات في شمال غرب سوريا باسرع
ما يمكن وتقديم المساعده الدوليه لاكبر
قدر ممكن من الضحايا في اشاره الى ان سكان
منا الشمال الغرب في سوريا يشعرون بانه تم
التخلي عنهم ويتطلعون للمساعدات في اقرب
وقت
وامجات ايضا طلب مبعوث الاتحاد الاوروبي
الى سوريا الدعم نيسكو النظام السوري بعدم
تسييف ملف المساعدات الانسانيه في الوقت
ذاته رفض المبعوث اتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي
بعدم تقديم ما يكفي من المساعدات للسوريين
في اعقاب الزلزال المدمره الذي ضرب مناطق
في سوريا وتركيا الاسبوع الماضي مضيفا بان
التكتل يقدم المساعدات الى سوريا منذ اكثر
من عشر سنوات بل ويقدم المزيد خلال ازمه
الزلزال وفق التعبيرهم اما مديرته صندوق
النقد الدولي كريستالينا قالت لنا الزلازل
او زلزال الذي دمر مناطق واسعه في سوريا
وتركيا تسبب فيما سياتي في ماسات هائله
للافراد ولكنه تسبب ايضا في تاثير كبير
جدا على الاقتصاد التركي واضافت جورجيفه
ان هذا الامر يفرض علينا ان نطور المزيد
من المرونه في مواجهه هذه الصدمات في
السياق ايضا توقعت
الامم المتحده ان تتجاوز تجاوز عدد قتل
زلزال تركيا وسوريا الاربعين الف
ينضم الينا من غازي عنتاب المدير الاقليمي
للاعلام والاتصال لدى لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه الياس ابو عطا السيد الياس مرحبا
بك معنا ما الذي يقدم الان من خلال لجنه
الانقاذ الدوليه في لمواجهه كارثه الزلزال
في تركيا تحديدا وكذلك في سوريا
سيدي الياس
طيب يبدو انه لدينا مشكله في الاتصالات
الان الوارده من تركيا
ربما عموما سيدي الياس هل انت معي الان هل
تسمعني
نعم
كنت اسال ما الذي تقدمه لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه الان بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر
نعم شكرا سيد خالد لاستضافه لجنه القاده
الدوليه حاليا قامت بتسريع الاستجابه لهذه
الازمه كارثيه في تركيا وسوريا
فلانا بدعم شركائنا في الميدان من اجل
مساعده
المنكوبين من خلال المساعدات النقديه
اضافه الى الرعايه الصحيه حيث نعلم بانه
في شمال غرب سوريا الرعايه الصحيه كانت
مرهقه بالفعل وفي الاصل فكذلك مع هذه
الازمه الجديده التي تضاف الى ما التحديات
التي يواجهونها في شمال البلاد فكان هناك
من
الواجب ان يتم
دعم هذه المراكز الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه
وغيرها من مراكز تقديم الخدمات الصحيه
سنقوم ايضا بمساعده النساء والاطفال
والاشخاص الضعفاء والفئات المستضعفه من
خلال الخدمات الحمايه وتوفير المراكز
الامنه كذلك سنقوم بتوفير الدعم الكائنه
في الميدان كي يقوموا بواجبهم بشكل عام من
اجل المساعده في تخطيط اكبر قدر من
الناس والفئات التي تضررت جراء هذه هذا
الزلزال العنيف الان ما حجم المساعدات
التي وصلت فعليا
كما نعلم حاليا ليس هناك معلومه
يمكن ان نؤكدها ولكن خلال يوم الخميس نعرف
بان كان اول
قافل المساعدات المتحده دخلت الى شمال غرب
سوريا اضافه الى اربعه عشر شاحنه اخرى
تابعتها خلال اليوم يومين الذين
تلهما
فنعلن نعلم بان حجم مساعده غير كافي
بالتاكيد فهناك عدد تحديات واجهت
الشركاء او او المستجبين الانسانيين في
الميدان منها حاله الطقس منها الضرر
الناتج الذي ادى الى تكسير الجسور وطرق
الرئيسيه مما ادى الى التعرق والحركه
الشاحنات والعبور بشكل عام وذلك كان موجود
في خلال المعبر الحدودي طرق كانت غير
كافيه او صحيه من اجل عبور القوافل كانت
تحديات كما كما تحدثت كالطقس البارد
الكفاءات غير الموجوده في الميدان
الماكينات او الادوات او الرافعات التي
يحتاجونها من اجل الالقاب الارواح العالقه
تحت الانقاد فكان العديد من التحديات
والمساعدات كانت بالتاكيد لم تصل في الوقت
المناسب ولكن نرى بانه يجب على على
المجتمع المدني ان يسرع
بدايه المساعدات وبالتمويل اضافه الى كل
كل الاطراف الموجوده من مساعد من الامم
المتحده الى من له
[موسيقى]
تاثير من اجل المساعده في تكثيف نقاط
العبور من اجل ادخال المساعدات
ووصولها الى من هم الحاجه لها في هذا
الوقت من الزمن فنحن في اليوم السابع وكما
حضرتك اخبرت هناك اكثر من 28,000 شخص
توفوا وهناك ما يقارب 26 مليون شخص تضرروا
من هذا الز في تركيا وسوريا فالوضع ماساوي
وكاله للغايه لذلك التمويل ونقاط العبور
لهذه المساعدات هو واجب انساني على الجميع
ان يتم الالتزام به من خلال متابعتك لماذا
قررت الامم المتحده اليوم بفشلها في
مساعده المنكوبين الاسباب تتعلق بما ذكرت
تحديات اللوجستيه الطقس دمار الطرق ام ان
هناك اسبابا اخرى اكبر هي التي كان لها
الدور او التاثير الاكبر في اعاقه وصول
هذه المساعده وانا اتحدث عن ما اشار اليه
وكيل امين عام الامم المتحده بالتصحيح
الاخفاقات وما ذكره ايضا مبعوث الاتحاد
الاوروبي بعدم تسييس ملف هذه المساعدات
[موسيقى]
واكرر بان الوضع كان كارثي جدا وجميع كان
على عندي هذه التحديات وحاولوا ان يقوموا
بتجاوزها ولكن للاسف لم يكن الحظ حليفهم
وما زلنا لدينا امل لانقاذ المزيد من
الارواح العالقه حتى ولو كنا في اليوم
السابع ولكن ايضا لا يمكن ان نخفي ان نقول
ندرك بان هناك تحديات ما زالت موجوده على
الميدان في سوريا وفي تركيا سواء
الوكيل الامين العام
المتحده داعي للتصحيح الاخفاقات عندما
يتحدث عن تصحيح الاخفاقات ماذا يقصد
تحديدا وهل يمكن بالفعل اليوم العمل على
تجاوز هذه العقبات ربما بايصال المساعدات
المطلوبه الى محتاجها في شمال غرب السوريه
كنشه انقاذ الدوليه لا نستطيع بالتاكيد
معرفه ما كان يقصد به الامين العام ولكن
نقول احدى التحديات التي كنا نادينا بها
منذ اليوم الاول هو نقاط العبور الحدوديه
بين تركيا وسوريا ونحن نعلم من خلال اخر
كنا نخسر نقاط عبور واخرها كان نقطه باب
السلام باب السلامه الذي كان منه يتم
ادخال العبور المساعدات التي تقودها الامم
المتحده فنحن نعلم كلما نقاط العبور كلما
خسرنا واحده منها تاثر الملايين من الناس
من جراء هذا
الفقدان لنقول من من هذه النقاط العبريه
فلا يسعدنا غير نقطه عبور واحده هي باب
الهوى ونعلم انه كان هناك تحديات وكان
عبور المساعدات بطيء خلال هذا الاسبوع
لذلك هذا كان واحد من الاسباب التي
تعترف بها الامم المتحده
بفشلها او بتعرقل الخدماتها لذلك ندعو بان
يكون هناك
اعطال اولويه لنقاط عبور لوصول المساعدات
فقط لكي يتم وصولها الى من هم بحاجه لها
هل هناك اي مؤشرات اللي هكذا تحرك هذه
هكذا خطوه الان سيدي الياس يعني من خلال
مراقبتك للمشهد الان
بحسب نرى حاليا حسب ما نشاهده في الاخبار
وما يحدث ميدان نرى بان هناك جهود نرحب
بها على مستوى الحكومات على مستوى الشركاء
المتحده نرى بان هناك
تكاثف من اجل تقديم المساعده ولكن للاسف
نعتقد انه يعني يمكن التقديم المزيد
والمزيد من المساعدات لان الارقام التي
نراها على على ارض الواقام رهيبه فعندما
نتحدث عن 26 مليون شخص تضرر فهذه ارقام
توازي ازمات اخرى تحدث على في العالم في
مناطق اخرى لذلك
نرحب بهذه المساعدات التي نراها ولكن يجب
السرعه في تنفيذ هذه الالتزامات والمساعده
في تقطيع
الرعايه والمساعده والمساعدات بكافه
انواعها لمن هم تضرروا من هذا الزلزال
شكرا جزيلا لك المدير الاقليمي للعلامه
الاتصال لدى لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه الياس
ابو عطا
نشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل من تلفزيون 24
الاسرائيلي بانسحاب فريق الانقاذ
الاسرائيلي من تركيا بسبب تهديدات امنيه
تنطلق بعد قليل الطائره السابعه ضمن الجسر
الجوي السعودي لمتضرري الزلزال من مطار
الملك خالد في رياض ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه هاني الصفيان هاني مرحبا بك هاني
مدى تحمل هذه الطائره
نعم اهلا بك خالد واهلا بالمشاهدين قناه
العربيه اذا تستعد الطائره السابعه ضمن
الجسر الجوي السعودي
مغادرتها هنا من مطار الملك خالد الدولي
الى مطار
اضنه في تركيا حيث تحمل مساعدات ولكن هذه
المساعدات هي مساعدات نوعيه او مختلفه وهي
تعتبر الطائره الاولى بالنسبه
للممثلين مركز الملك سلمان الذين غادروا
الاسبوع الماضي ورفعوا الاحتياجات اذا
نستطيع القول ان هذه المساعدات هي
المساعدات التي اتت بعد رفع الاحتياجات من
قبل ممثلين ملك مركز الملك سلمان لغاته
والاعمال الانسانيه والذي غادر الاسبوع
الماضي الى الاراضي التركيه طبعا هذه
المساعدات هي تحمل مولدات كهربائيه عددها
اثنى عشر مولدا كهربائيا هذه المولدات حجم
الطاقه الكهربائيه فيها
1.5 ميجا اي يعني ان بامكان هذه
تشغيل اكثر من ثمان مستشفيات سواء ميدانيه
او كذلك
ثابته اضافه الى هذه الموليدات هناك اسره
طبيه وهي من المساعدات النوعيه الجديده او
الاحتياجات التي رفعها ممثلين مركز الملك
سلمان عند عند وصولهم الى تركيا وهذه هي
الاسره الطبيه اضافه الى اجهزه اوكسجين
وكذلك ادويه يحتاجها المتضررين في مثل هذه
الكوارث طبعا لا ننسى ان هناك احتماليه
ايضا بزياده عدد فريق الانقاذ والبحث الذي
غادر
الاسبوع الماضي الى الاراضي التركيه وهم
فريق متخصص في البحث والانقاذ لديهم خبره
عاليه ورخصه عاليه في مجال البحث والانقاذ
ايضا هناك من الممكن ان تكون هناك اضافه
ايضا في عدد الاليات وكذلك المعدات الخاصه
بعمليات البحث والانقاذ قد ترسلها
السعوديه اجمالي ما ارسلته السعوديه عبر
الطائرات او الجسر الجوي حتى هذه اللحظه
يفوق ال500 طن لدينا الطائره السابعه وهي
من نوع بوينج
777 هي الان تستعد لحمل هذه الشحنه هذه
الشحنه تزن قرابه التسعين طن طبعا لو
نشاهد الحاويات الموجوده على ساحه هذا على
ساحه المطار او
القريبه من الطائره نجدها ايضا هناك
مساعدات ايوائيه اضافه الى المساعدات التي
وصلت الى تركيا وكذلك دخلت جزء منها الى
سوريا لا ننسى ايضا انا من ضمن ايضا
المساعدات هي
خيام والخيام التي ارسلتها الى السعوديه
حتى هذه اللحظه تكفي الى 5000 اسره في
باستطاعه الاسر الناجون من جراء هذه
الزلازل او ايضا من هم موجودون في سوريا
الاستفاده من هذه بعد ان اوصلتها او
اوصلها مركز الملك سلمان لغاته والعمال
الانسانيه ووقف على محتاجينها طبعا الجسر
الجوي ايضا من المتوقع ان يستمر خلال
اليومين الماضيين بحسب رفع الاحتياجات
اللازمه من قبل الممثلين مركز الملك سلمان
لغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه الموجودون هناك
والذين يقفون على ارض الواقع المكان
المتضرر من الزلازل سواء في سوريا او كذلك
او سواء في تركيا او من خلال شركائهم في
سوريا ورفع احتياجات جديده وكذلك متطلبات
اخرى مختلفه بحسب حاجه المتضررين وحسب
حاجه العمل
لعمليات البحث والانقاذ
ستكون او ستتجه الى نفس الوجهه بدايه الى
مطار اضنه ثم الى
المنكوبين او ربما الى الاراضي السوريه
والتركيه يعني
طبعا الطائره هي
مجدوله على ان تتجه الى اضنه ولكن من خلال
ما شاهدناه الفتره الماضيه من خلال الجسر
الجوي بعض
الطائرات كانت تتجه الى اضنه ولكن كانت
تحولها
ويحولها الطيران التركي الى مطار عنتاب
بحسب بسبب الازدحامات لاعداد الطائرات عند
وصول هذه الطائرات سواء في اضنه او انتساب
يتم
توزيعها عبر شاحنات متخصصه هذه الشاحنات
يتم توزيعها جزء منها يدخل الى سوريا عبر
شركاء مركز الملك سلمان لغاته والعمل
الانسانيه وجزء اخر ايضا يتم توزيعه
للمتضررين في في تركيا بعد التنسيق او بعد
او بعد التنسيق مع الممثلين والمختصين
هناك في الحكومه التركيه لكن من خلال
المشاهد التي
شاهدناها الفتره الماضيه الرسول على هذه
المساعدات كانت تصل الى المحتاجين شاهدنا
ايضا فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي يقوم
بعمليه بحث وايضا تشغيل او عمل اجهزه
التقنيه او الحديثه المتطوره التي
صاحبته في هذه الرحله البحث وكذلك ايضا
مساعده مركز الملك سلمان للمنتظرين من
خلال نصب الخيام وكذلك لتوزيع اسئله
الغذائيه وها هي اليوم المساعدات الطبيه
تتجه او سوف تتجه بعد قليل الى مطار تركيا
او مطار اضنه في تركيا وايضا بالفعل او
بكل تاكيد سوف يتم توزيعها جزء منها في
تركيا وجزء منها في سوريا المواجهه الصعبه
اليوم التي تواجه مركز الملك سلمان
رغم الشركاء في الداخل السوري ورغم ايضا
وصول هذه المساعدات الا انه تصعب عليه
الاصول المتطلبات اللازمه والاحتياجات
اللازمه من قبل
الاعضاء او الفريق الموجود هناك في الداخل
السوري بسبب الاوضاع الراهنه هو سبب
وصعوبه وصول هذه المساعدات ورغم ذلك وصل
جزء كبير من المساعدات الى داخل سوريا
وتحديدا الى شمال سوريا وهي المنطقه
المتضرره تحديدا الواقعه بالقرب من جنوب
تركيا شكرا جزيلا لك هاني الصفيان مراسل
العربيه من مطار الملك خالد الدولي فريق
يلا بدنا الوسائم
[موسيقى]
سوريا حيث رصدت كاميرا العربيه توقفا نحو
100 شاحنه محمله بالوقود والمواد الاغاثيه
ارسلت من مناطق الاداره الكرديه ولا تزال
عالقه في معبر ام جلود الفاصله بين مناطق
سيطره قسد ومناطق الفصائل المواليه لتركيا
التي ترفض مرور هذه الشاحنات الى ادلب
هي الصور الحصريه لشاحنات الوقود التي
قدمتها الاداره الذاتيه
للمنكوبين من الزلزال في شمال غرب البلاد
والتي لا تزالوا حتى الان عالقه في المعبر
طبعا نادين هذه الشاحنات هي بدايه القافله
التي ستصل الى هنا هناك ايضا 42 شاحنه
تحمل المواد الطبيه واغاثيه مقدمه من
مجموعه من المنظمات التي تعمل في شمال شرق
البلاد بمعنى اننا نتحدث عن حوالي 100
شاحنه من المفترض ان تدخل الى هذا عبر هذا
المعبر الى المناطق المنكوبه لكن حتى الان
لا توجد موافقه من الطرف الاخر للسماح
بعبورها
يبقى معنا من معبر ام جلود في منبج مراسل
العربيه جمعه جمعه مرحبا بك هل ما زالت
هذه الشاحنات متوقفه او عالقه او ممنوعه
من الدخول مرحبا بكم بالساده المشاهدين في
تركيا نعم انا الان في معبر ام الجلود
الفاصل بين مناطق الاكراد حيث اقف وبين
مناطق المعارضه كما تظهر في الصوره هذا هو
الجدار الذي يفصل او بوابه المعبر التي
تفصل بين مناطق الاداره الذاتيه ومناطق
المعارضه في شمال غرب البلاد لا يزال
الوضع على حاله دون اي تغيير لم تدخل واي
واحده من الشاحنات التي
ارسلتها الاداره الذاتيه وعددها هنا في
المعبر كما تلاحظ 30 شاحنه محمله بالوقود
اي مادتين البنزين والمازوت المطلوبه بشكل
سريع في المناطق المتضرريه ليشحها هناك
ايضا هناك سبع شاحنات محمله بالمواد
الاغاثيه
موجوده مقدمه من الاهالي ولم تدخل حتى
الان
يتوقع ايضا ان تصل خلال يعني ساعات 42
شاحنه لمحمله بالمواد الطبيه والاغاثيه
مقدمه من منظمات المجتمع المدني والاهالي
الى هذه المنطقه وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
حوالي 100 شاحنه هنا في معبر ام جلود من
المفترض ان تدخل الى مناطق المعارضه ليس
ببعيد من هنا نحن يعني على بعد حوالي عشر
دقائق من معبر التائهه وهو معبر ايضا
تتواجد فيه 100 شاحنه اخرى اضافه الى
شاحنات وسيارات اسعاف ارسلتها الاداره
الذاتيه ويفترض ان تصل الى مناطق النظام
في حلب لكن هناك تاسيس لهذه المساعدات
وعرقله للدخولها الى سوى الى مناطق النظام
او الى مناطق المعارضه بخصوص مناطق
المعارضه كان هناك لقاء منذ حوالي ساعه
بين الاداره واطراف وطرف في المعارضه
الى الداخل و وفاوض لا اعرف اي جهه لكنه
عادل الاداره الذاتيه وقال له بانه لا
يستطيع استلام هذه المساعدات واعتقد انهم
كانوا من الدفاع المدني اذا يعني
نعم فشلت هذه المفاوضات يبدو ان يعني هناك
اكثر من جهه تتحكم بقرار ادخال هذه
الجهه التي تتحكم بهذا القرار جمعه ولماذا
يعني ما الاسباب التي تمنع دخول هذه
المساعدات ان كان لديك اي معلومات
طبعا الخلافات السياسيه والعسكريه بين
الاداره الذاتيه والمعارضه لا تزال قائمه
كانت سكان المنكوبين سي او حتى المتبرعين
من هذه المنطقه يعني يتطلعون الى تذويب
جبل الخلافات بين الطرفين على الاقل الفتح
المعابر
لترك السوريين يساعدون بعضهم في هذه
المحنه كذلك لم يحدث الاكراد يقولون بان
تركيا هي من تعرقل دخول هذه
المساعدات الى مناطقهم لاسيما وان يعني
ايضا الحكومه المؤقته كانت الازهرت بيان
منذ حوالي ساعتين قال بانها ترحب بمساعدات
الاهالي والعشائر كان واضح ان البيان يعني
المساعدات المقدمه من قسد والاداره
الذاتيه اي ان الخصومه السياسيه والعسكريه
لا تزال قائمه والمساعدات لا تنجح بدخول
المعابر بسبب وجود هذه العراقيل السياسيه
والعسكريه اما من جهه النظام
قالت بان النظام طلب الحصول على 80% من
المساعدات التي تود ادخالها
اريد ان نتعرف على المشهد حيث انت من
زوايا مختلفه ايضا جمعه اذا كنت تستطيع
ذلك
اربعه
ايام سمعت من البعض منهم بانهم يريدون
الوصول الى النتيجه اما بدخول هذه
المساعدات عبر المعبر المغلق او عودتهم
لانهم يفترشون ايضا هذا هذا هذا الخلاء
سيحصلون على الطعام ايضا هذه الشاحنات
انت احمل كما قلت الوقود البنزين والمازوت
بشكل عام الوقود يعني نادر وطلب اساسي في
عموم مناطق سوريا حتى في مناطق الاداره
الذاتيه وهي الاكثر حاجه في المناطق
المنكوبه لان معظم الاليات الثقيله سواء
كانت الرافعات او الجراثات والنقارات او
حتى المولدات الكهربائيه تعمل على هذه
المواد وهذه المواد سوف تساعد فرق الانقاذ
والبحث في عمليه ازاله الركام والبحث عن
ناجين ان بقي هناك ناجين تحت هذه الالقاب
رغم ان فرص جدا او يعني الوصول الى الجثث
التي يترقب يعني
المئات من العوائل الوصول الى خبر عن
اهاليهم الموجودين تحت الالقاب سوى كانوا
يعني قتله او على قيد الحياه
نريد ان نشاهد ايضا الصوره من الجانب
المقابل
للمنطقه التي من المفترض ان تدخل اليها
هذه الشاحنات
عذرا يعني
هذا هو هذا هو اكثر على المنطقه على
المعبر الذي من المفترض ان تدخل منه
المعبر امامها المساعدات طبعا المعبر يقع
في مدينه منبج على طرف الاداره الذاتيه
بينما من مناطق المعارضه فنحن نتحدث عن
مدينه جرابلس هذا المعبر في العاده كان
يستخدم للحركه التجاريه وايضا
مرور الاهالي بين الطرفين اليوم يعني
تحاول الاداره ان تجعله منفذ لدخول
المساعدات لقربه من المناطق
المنقوبه اي مساعدات في الايام الماضيه
هذا المعبر جمعه
هذا المابر لم يشرد دخول اي مساعدات سواء
كانت من الاداره الذاتيه او حتى من
الاهالي او من المنظمات كما قلت هناك
قافله للمنظمات مؤلفه من 240 شاحنه ستجد
باتجاه
النار هي موجوده
قبل حلول الليل او لربما يعني يتم تاجير
الوصول هذه الشاحنه لصباح يوم شكرا جزيلا
لك جمعه كاش مراسل العربيه من معبر ومن
جلود
تابع عمليات من البناء البارحه
بعيدا عن اخبار الزلزال نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر حيث اعلنت السعوديه رساله اول رائده
فضاء سعوديه ورائد فضاء سعودي الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه خلال الربع الثاني من
العام الجاري من المقرر ان تلتحق رائده
الفضاء ريان برناوي ورائد الفضاء على
القرني الى طاقم مهمه اي اكس اثنين
الفضائيه بهدفي بناء القدرات الوطنيه في
مجال الرحلات الماهوله لاجل البشريه واضحا
بان الرحله العلميه ستنطلق من الولايات
المتحده الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه وسيتضمن
البرنامج
تدريب رائده ورائده فضاء اخرين
نتابع الان مع الرئيس التنفيذي المكلف
للهيئه السعوديه للفضاء الدكتور محمد
التميمي سيد محمد اهلا وسهلا بك معي دكتور
مدى وراء ارسال هذا الطاقم الان في هذا
التوقيت وما هي الطبيعه المهام التي
سيقومون بها
وعلى الساده والسيدات المشاهدين في
البدايه ارفع اسماء ايات الشكر والعرفان
للمقام مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين اسمه
سيدي ولي العهد على ما قدمه من دعم وتمكين
لا محدود في سبيل رفعه الوطن وتحقيق طموح
ابنائه حقيقه تحت الرئله تاتي الرحله ضمن
برنامج المملكه لرواد الفضاء والمعلن عنها
سابقا من الهيئه السعوديه الفضاء ويمثل
احد معجزات مساع المملكه نحو الرياده حيث
تهدوا المشاركه قدرات الوطنيه في مجال
الرحلات المهفوله لاجل البشريه وخدمه
الانسانيه والاستفاده من الفرص الواعده
التي يقدمها قطاع الفضاء عالميا والمساهمه
في الابحاث العلميه والابتكار في عدد من
المجالات ذات الاولويه مثل الصحه
والاستدامه وتقنيه الفضاء
وما هي طبيعه العمل الذي سيقومون كيف يمكن
ان نتصور ويتخيل من سيقومون به في في هذه
الرحله
حقيقه اليوم اعلن عن اربع رواد الفضاء
منهم اثنين اعلن عن توقيت رحلتهم من
المقرره تنطلق اول رائده فضاء السعوديه
ريانه برناوي مع رائد الفضاء علي القرني
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه خلال الربع
الثاني من هذا العام من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والبرنامج يتضمن تاهيل وتدريب
رائدي الفضاء علي الغامدي ومريم فردوس كما
ذكرت اخوي خالد على كافه متطلبات المهمه
تعول المملكه على البرنامج رواد الفضاء في
تعزيز مكانتها في السباق العالمي نحو
الفضاء واستكشافه ورفع مكانتها في الخارطه
الدول التي تتسابق الى الفضاء وتستثر في
علوم المتخصصه يقود البرنامج التفعيل
ابتكارات العلميه على مستوى علوم الفضاء
وتعزيز قدره المملكه على اجراء ابحاث
الخاصه بشكل مستقل بما ينعكس ايجابا على
مستقبل الصناعه والوطن وشيء مهم جدا اخوي
خالد الهام الطلاب في مجال العلوم التقنيه
والهندسه والرياضيات وتنميه راس المال
البشري من خلال جذب المواهب وتطوير
المهارات اللازمه الاثار المتوقع بعد
انتهاء هذه المهمه الى اي مدى يمكن ان يصل
الحقيقه البرنامج اعلن عنه واول الرحلات
التي تم الاعلان عن توقيته الرحله رائده
الفضاء السعودي ريان البرناوي ورائد
الفضاء علي القرني طبعا تعد رحلات الفضاء
الماهوله مقياس لتفوق الدول وتنافسيه
عالميا في العديد من المجالات مثل التقدم
التقني والهندسي والبحث العلمي والابتكار
تعد هذه الرحله التاريخيه حيث تجعل
المملكه من الدول القليله في العالم التي
تجمع رائد الفضاء من نفس الجنسيه علامات
محطه الفضاء الدوليه في التوقيت ذاته شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور محمد التميمي رئيس التنفيذ
المكلف للهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت هذه او في ختام هذه التغطيه نذكر
بعض الاخبار العاجله من وزير العادل
التركي الذي اشر او الذي قال بان حكومه
التركيه او كافه العشرات والسرقه خلال
الزلزال وايضا الحكومه التركيه تقوم
بتحقيق موسع مع بعض مقاول البناء بسبب
انهيار الاف البنايات جراء الزلزال
بالاضافه الى انشاء مكاتب تحقيق ايضا في
جرائم زلزال والوفيات والاصابات كانت
العدد التركيه اعلنت عن اعتقال 62 من
مقاولي البناء في اطار التحقيقات في
انهيار المباري جرائد الزلزال واكدت فتح
تحقيقات بسبب هذه المباني المنهاره الغير
مطابقه كما اشار البعض للمواصفات
والمقاييس المعتمده كنا ايضا قد ذهبنا الى
غازي عنتاب ومازال فريق الالقاد السعودي
يعمل
ربما انقاذ الطفل من تحت الانقاذ بعدما
سمع صوته خلال فتره عمل هذا الفريق نهايه
هذه الساعه
بتعطيتنا ايضا مستمره الزميله ميسون عزام
تلتقيكم بعد قليل الى اللقاء